هذه هي المشاهد الفوضوية التي نشرتها
مجموعة مرتزقة فاغنر ما يقولونه هو أن
معسكرهم في الغابة ضربه
الجيش الروسي
في إزالة الأشجار ويبدو أن
بعضها قد تحطم بقماش متناثر من
أغصانها
من خلال جرح في التربة
واشتعلت النيران وماذا  يبدو أنه مخبأ مدمر،
وهناك صور مروعة أيضًا
للجثة والشجيرات بالإضافة إلى
سبعة أجزاء من الجسم.
تنفي وزارة الدفاع الروسية أي
دور لها في هذا، لكن زعيم فاغنر الغاضب
يتعهد بالانتقام
لأولئك الذين دمروا رجالنا اليوم إلى
جانب عشرات الآلاف.
ستتم معاقبة حياة الجنود الروس،
ولا أطلب من أحد أن يبدي أي مقاومة. ستتم
استعادة العدالة للقوات ومن ثم
العدالة لعموم روسيا، إن
التهديد بالعنف يشكل الآن
تحديًا كبيرًا لسلطة
الرئيس بوتين،
يقول الكرملين  يتم اتخاذ جميع الإجراءات اللازمة
والآن
فتح جهاز الأمن الروسي
قضية جنائية فيما يقولون إنه دعوة
للتمرد المسلح،
ويبدو أن صبر بريجوسيان قد
نفد أخيرًا
رئيس فاغنر الذي
لعب مرتزقته دورًا رئيسيًا في حرب أوكرانيا
كانت على خلاف منذ فترة طويلة مع القيادة العسكرية الروسية التي
اتهمتها مرارًا وتكرارًا بإساءة
التعامل مع الصراع،
لكن الأسابيع الأخيرة شهدت
تصاعد التوترات بعد أن أمر الكرملين جميع
المرتزقة الروس بتوقيع عقود
مع وزارة الدفاع في خطوة اعتبرت
بمثابة حملة على فاغنر في الساعات
السابقة.  أدت الضربة المزعومة على
معسكر فاغنر بريجوسيان إلى تصعيد حربه
الكلامية متهمة وزارة الدفاع
بخداع البلاد للقيام بغزو غير مبرر
في فبراير من العام الماضي،
في 24 فبراير، لم يحدث شيء غير عادي
ولكن وزارة الدفاع كانت
تحاول خداع الجمهور لخداعهم.
الرئيس ويقول إنه كان هناك
عدوان مجنون من جانب أوكرانيا
وأنهم كانوا سيهاجموننا جنبًا إلى جنب
مع الناتو،
لم تكن هناك حاجة للحرب من أجل
إعادة المواطنين الروس إلى حضننا
ولم تكن هناك حاجة إليها من أجل تجريد
أوكرانيا من سلاحها ونزع سلاحها.  إنه
انتقاد جريء وخطير لحرب روسيا التي
قد تغرق البلاد في حالة من الاضطراب،
أوه نعم
أجنبي